if you ask a thousand dumb questions and
you listen to the answer then you know a
thousand things some of them deep that
you didn't know before you should always
ask a stupid question and that doesn't
mean the sort of question that someone
who wasn't paying attention would ask if
you're listening to someone and you
don't understand what they're saying and
maybe you're in a room full of people
and you think you're the only person
stupid enough to not get it which is
very rarely the case by the way if you
reveal that ignorance to yourself and to
the other person they can Rectify it and
if you do that a thousand times you're
not ignorant anymore and this is a real
Pathway to success too you do this
because you ask real questions in your
podcast and Rogan does this Rogan's
always trying to be a little smarter
than he already is and then that works
this is why it's so useful to listen to
people you might find out where you're
stupid and then you could stop being
stupid